this one
take on the fate yup
beaver gambit what is beaver gambit if
you guys wanna
throw me off you can just say uh a name
of a random gambit and and you will
achieve your goal
95 b4 equal i mean
takes c4 what's the point of that what's
the point of giving up a pawn like that
i'm trying to understand
sultai is uh
is a blind follower of jonathan i guess
you see jonathan instead go my
my minions share
share the knowledge of
the beaver gambit
make the beaver gambit great again
and gm sultai said
sir yes sir and now he is
sharing this unique piece of knowledge
with everyone
everyone he sees on twitch
how's it going uh oh hello hello justin
going pretty well i am
i'm playing a bunch of nonsense i hear
you've been trash talking the beaver
gambit what no what is this all about i
don't know i don't know what what the
heck are you talking about what the heck
is beaver gambit i'm clocking it trash
talk something i don't know
i mean but just in general my my take
on on many different gambits is is
solely negative because
in my personal experience gambas just
don't work so you're not a believer in
the beef i'm i'm not a bit i'm i mean i
like beavers you know but you know uh
you know yesterday it was an
international beaver day really yeah so
i had the international beaver day
thanks but i don't know if you celebrate
i certainly do but but why would i why
would you congratulate me if you know
that i'm not a believer
that's a great point ah that is a great
point uh okay
anyways i'll let you finish your
tournament yeah it's just we need to
settle this over the board and have a
beaver battle okay sure i'm just saying
yeah i'm not dying away i'm down i am
totally uh i'm trying to find a way to
win this there's gotta be one i need to
finish this game quickly
are you ready i'm ready like you you you
tell me what you're doing does chad know
what's happening we are about to have
the world's largest beaver battle all
right
i come on the stream
you're in here talking about how the
beaver gambit is so bad that's the first
thing i hear you're clearly not a
believer in the beaver i i'm not and i'm
here to change your mind okay sure you
want to i challenge you to one game but
okay
totally totally gonna prove
on the i'll we'll up the stakes too how
about this i tell you what you're not a
believer you beat me i never make a
youtube video about the beaver ever
again what do you mean that's good
content what they talking about
throw away my best content what the heck
yeah that's how confident i am don't
sabotage yourself what the heck
if you lose however
you're gonna need to confess that you
are a believer in the beaver do you
accept these odds uh of course yeah i i
have no no problem yeah i mean i i i
always i always said that uh that these
gambits they are good as one-time
weapons most of them are right but in a
great scale of things
you know if you play them more than one
time in your life spans play more than
one person
it's just once it's just one and done
i am sending you a challenge cool sure
let's go it's suddenly getting really
cold here that your your writing is do
you need me to explain it or no no no p
people somebody in chat already uh
already uh
is it knight c6 v6 e6 you say oh you're
right you're right right and this stuff
here we go beaver gamut cb4 beaver
gambit okay
okay
all right you've already played an
unusual line let's see it's good
that's exactly and this is exactly what
we need to know
that we've played a bad line but that's
that's that's that's my entire life
that's that's what i'm known for playing
bad lines but still winning games
all right it'll be less instructive for
the viewers though you got to take that
into account they probably want to see
how would i know how would they know
that that's that's what's was
instructive like i don't know what i'm
doing
i mean it looks
uh i'm it looks like i'm up a pawn so
far
i can understand why you would think
that yeah
that's you know i i see stuff with my
eyes and that's that's how i feel about
the position you see that's why i'm i'm
a big advocate for taking b2 and b7
pawns in any opening
because i see the free pawn i take it
and and then i usually suffer for the
rest of the game but i end up winning
how do you feel about that move uh it's
it's a move i i see another pawn and i
grab it oh wow yeah
what about this one and this one yeah
that's that's kind of what i was
expecting all right i'm glad we're on
the same page yeah
how do you feel about queen f3
yeah this one yeah pretty good pretty
good okay i just want to make sure we're
on the same page here i mean it's
probably like completely winning for god
at this point but who cares i have like
two extra pawns
yeah uh
okay here
i will go here
deal with that
i mean you're you're you are throwing
pawns at me just like there is no
tomorrow okay just it's about peace
activity this is kind of the secret to
the people i've been i've been
advocating advocates for peace activity
as well
i'm happy with them but i i'm also being
a big advocate for extra material
okay
and trading when you are
you're okay i understand the kind of
person you are now yeah that's okay
i'm not going to say i'm happy about it
no you should be because you're winning
by force so you probably should be okay
i will go here that's not the move i was
implying but i can't
did i have a better move i could have
you could have just taken on d6
and taken on g6 and bishop e5
and because because my king is on the
last string you'll have rook c8 and
winning and winning the rookies by
trying to recapture yeah
same things that sound very true
uh but that is why
okay
i mean so you basically already proved
the points that you can literally win
the game very quickly if your opponent
doesn't know what they're doing
which is the point of most of these
gambits
most people i find
don't come away with that whoever wins
no matter the quality of the game yeah
most people will just come away with the
idea that that is the better opening
yeah no that's not true it is not true
but i'm saying that's what whatever
happens here that's how it shall be
remembered
that's how it works on the internet no
no no it's bad i'm not saying anything
that's not a good i'm not saying
i refuse
yeah i i clearly see the point and i
agree i i agree that i accept that
that's that's the the message of this of
this match
okay so i should be winning at this
point i just need to be careful
the first thing i need to make sure
to do is to just hide my king and then
be up three points three points three
points
points pawns
one thing
okay yeah i see see and now and you are
telling me that you don't like pawns
there it is
don't don't get any of the wrong ideas
oh my god
have i missed something jonathan you had
that most amazing the most delightful
when no ever ever still don't see oh i
can take your rook oh my god i could
take on h6 no no i win but you have the
right idea oh check first
it's
amazing i still don't quite see it okay
yes
locate rocket ship oh god
yeah
all right guys
that's no more messing around i've been
having geography
we've been having a good old-fashioned
time no but i'm not always fashioned
what do you mean by that what is old
fashioned supposed to mean
you know man this is like how back in
the old days is how they used to have
fun
but i'm done with that the really good
in good old days they had access to lee
chess and that was just
like i'm like oh yeah let's play it like
gaming
[Laughter]
you win yeah like there's no defense
i'm upset
yeah but you you gotta beat me at least
like three times so that's that's okay
you have proven the point check me then
too would you say you are a believer in
the yeah yeah and of course once again i
i never said i don't believe in a
one-time power of gambling okay
but they see the problem is that by the
way we're both a winner yeah exactly
yeah but you see for me if i just decide
to get a little bit serious about it and
pull up you know pull up the stockfish
whatever
17.1.2 whatever newest version they have
and and analyze it with the stock
pressure i'll i'll just be able to just
kill the probably kill your gambit
i will then
change it you might do something
completely different exactly and you you
how do you feel about this so
essentially the point is
play this stuff nobody ever prepares it
because it's not what the computer would
say anyway it's just some random stuff
and then when somebody actually looks it
up which is rare you can just move the
gold post by playing some other tricky
variations so they feel about this
approach so there's always a risk
because on my level
especially in classical games people can
just find their refutation most of the
time so that's why like in an overboard
yeah exactly yeah okay yeah so when
would you how far could i get twenty to
twenty two hundred i would say is at the
top yeah i would say
feeder master and i am i am level and
higher is already very very uh
very very uh
dangerous
to try something what about i am
low gm level like blitz yeah for sure
yeah i mean i mean you see you see
magnus play like all these all these
like
like though
you know sacrifice sacrifices all the
time and blitz and and bullets against
against 26 27 100 feels like literally
anybody yeah exactly yeah yeah and he's
doing well it's this just proves the
point that yeah and bulletin board no
one is safe yeah it's just now when i
say from blunders and i want to say from
surprises losing on time and stuff like
that you know it's it's a good it's a
good strategy yeah these these things
are like really really strong in
in in speed speed chess i would say
would you like to see some beaver gambit
theory people are asking a little bit
about it sure or yeah of course you go
you you won i'll get your shoes
okay
yeah i i don't i don't mind yeah i i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna sell i'll be
using it
but
but just just to show people what i
thought
he was a believer don't flip it
strategically so you're like i love the
beaver yeah don't worry we'll do some
editing okay
dude this is the best
okay so now it has it has a name huh
it's against paulson
against paulson v we go
uh c3 c3 yeah knight of six here here
yeah b4 b4 gambit it all makes sense now
delayed alapan variation is so that's
what i generally play as white
you actually play this on there on a
consistency so for a while so i have
another idea here so i was playing the
beaver gambit but it was not popular and
so i have to like change it because i
just got to play what's popular like i
make up something and then i'm like it
does well i keep playing it or if people
don't like it then i just change so
there's other crazy ideas
but this
but yesterday was international beaver
day so we brought it back
so
we can look at some other interesting
lines
you can take the pawn is like what
everybody does i mean of course there's
a main beaver trap after c4
most people if you like this is the
master database there's four games
that's like not useful if you go to the
lee chess database to see how the normal
people play you don't use it because you
you like only care what masters play but
normal people got to use the lead chess
database now there's a lot more games
uh okay
knight b6 is what most people play but i
played knight e7 right yeah yeah and
then if you hide now hide chat for a sec
don't look at the database for just a
second hide it somehow magically hide it
beautiful masters would never be here
now it goes d4
and what would you play here as black i
mean obviously d6 just loses but if you
don't play d6 and c5 comes and black who
loses a major amount of space right
i suppose that might be the i mean i
guess bishop it should be seven i guess
interesting
so yeah then this is interesting that
you so you identified the first trap if
you look at really
well look at the database it's oh like
50 of the people why would people play
d6 or d5 that's what everybody does
okay but like you're looking 100 out of
two right that's what i mean but like
normal people immediately blunder here
and you win quickly
and then they go in the comments and no
nobody would actually but everybody does
okay i mean you're talking about blitz
and bullet games though so yeah
everybody any nobody would in classical
probably not even if you're like 17 1600
i mean people would immediately say
think that oh should i put 96 now how do
i get myself out of this mess probably
just bishop to seven castle all right
you don't like that all right no it's
fine
okay there's other variations like 197
that's like actually the normal one well
not east what about that e7 uh somehow
you're like i've had a game here which
you might be able to find see black has
black has much better results here it's
true
how did i there was at some point i had
some prep here and i had one good game i
can no longer remember anything so i
played i played this way which
is was not ideal but it's not too bad i
i would take plus point five oh yes true
we could start with we could just
analyze our game for this
is this actually what happened
well but i only need to we can see how
well we actually did
i mean probably horrible right because
[Laughter]
look at that confused
chess player with the beaver gambit are
you kidding me i mean are you you should
have you should have bamboozled how many
double question marks did we have like
that's crazy you should have just taken
these six too yeah because you haven't
you have a superior center so
so if i like i'm playing you in like a
real game let's just you're kind of
focused on this real game stuff like
blitz on the internet is not real stuff
okay yeah what i mean i should obviously
opt for this over some like normal
opening you are also prepared no i'm not
prepared for any opening see if you're
thinking for example i'm not prepared i
don't know like i really want to have
you play the queen's gambit accepted
against me when i could rather have this
yeah exactly chance exactly because in
queens gamut accepted you can literally
force a queen trade line and then
they'll spend seven hours
i don't want to play the end game
against you i want to like hope for a
tactic
now yeah do you i don't i don't know if
if you're hoping for an aggressive games
and yeah you will not i'm not going to
play paulson
and you will not get it you know
if i don't want it you will not get it
with me
that's the problem with tough guys
it's like
yeah and it's unless this one actually
makes more sense because well i don't
have to spend additional additional move
to get the bishop out so that makes
the most sense to me actually i'm not
sure about point a seven and
yeah so
i can just take on e5 like it was just
such a bad game blunders everywhere
look at that c5 you gave me i was
playing like a champ up to this point
yeah i see look at that not exactly the
best move but definitely one of these
what move they got me the winning
position okay
yeah i i knew it was if queen of three
actually uh
an s3 wasn't as as great but yeah here
somewhere you had this
you had this
amazing the fun part
amazing and then yeah just get rid we'll
add it amazing rookie eighth rookie
chait look at this
boom immediately over made in two i
would have been the champion of the
world yeah you would have everyone would
be cheering mm-hmm
oh how nice is shade queen g7 or kh8
using the fact that the opponent spent
oh my gosh and
yeah
i could have been the champion you but
it's okay it happens sometimes sometimes
you sometimes you miss you miss an
opportunity of your lifetime but it'll
be way more it's okay don't worry about
it see here you also missed rook takes
f7 which could have also been very nice
for white
but yeah and after this it's yeah it was
it was a fun game i can't i could i can
take it i know i didn't it's all right
if you didn't like the game you could be
like man i kind of didn't like it and
now you're kind of taking up all my time
i might get it i mean no what i mean who
takes i i
nobody is taking my time i'm here to
have fun and entertain people on stream
okay and we're gonna get 2700 oh yeah i
mean i guess i guess i need to learn a
couple of gambits like beaver gamber to
get to 2700 i mean i'm not sure these
days anything any small change can make
a difference you know for people like me
it's like it's all about micromanagement
at this level you know it's
you know it's just just a tiny little
piece of knowledge that i have over my
opponent can can make a drastic change
like i'm you know in beaver game but now
i see i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
cruise are you gonna be i don't you
probably don't want to tell all your
opponents but you're gonna be using this
and like oh of course yeah i mean easy
yeah easily if i if i if i if i'm faster
how many hours should your opponents
really invest into refuting the i would
say probably two maybe three minutes
i mean
i'm sorry stand you up you could have
like they'd be oh i gotta spend weeks
i mean two three minutes will stop you
we'll probably do it okay did you dig so
yeah
it seemed like it was like minus one
close to minus one if it's close to
minus one it means that
pawn sacrifices just essentially just
gives gives up a pawn
um
for
very little so i wish you would have
played the main line there's even more
complicated fun there's so much more
well what is considered to be the main
line the main line the main line of the
beaver gambit come on like
what does it mean
well knight b6 just was super bad so
knight sees that's the seven
tropical beaver and you go a3 or d4
so d6 all right now yeah don't turn your
engine off for a second okay
i want to battle the best
it's
two at this point you saw it it's minus
two man i'm not worried okay just get
give it don't look you can't look at
what other people have already done you
know come on get that all off there man
get that all off all right you can see
what the map the mad look at all these
strong players oh the strong players who
play horrible chess yeah they're so good
okay
all right yeah you got to get them off
too i got to challenge you wait what
you're being challenged right now this
is all part of the beaver i mean i i
still wish i was saying i saw that what
would you play here
was it b5 move i mean i think i saw what
what this dogfish was saying b5 was some
very good move all right b5 is an
excellent move nobody has ever played it
i don't think yeah i'm no longer having
fun analyzing with you you know all the
best moves i mean i just so happen to
see what
[Laughter]
well obviously i don't know i wouldn't
know b5 so what do you think would be
normal
h6 and then castle you just cause you're
worried about the greed gift yeah
exactly so just my first impression
of course not of course not yeah
i think i would say no i mean i don't
know i don't even have to calculate that
it's just instantly saying no so most
people play knight c6 and then don't
calculate knight six i would like play
anything most people know maybe make
some sense as well uh-huh okay
so nice you want to look at knight c6 i
wanted
i suppose i want to look at castles
yeah i do
i think it's actually interesting
okay
here so if this
you have to play games successfully h4
yeah
no the black is fine but can you solve
it like you would not do this obviously
but if you want to have fun
and knock yourself out it's calculating
for no reason wait wait why knock myself
out i mean this looks completely lost
for what why would i knock myself out it
is obviously very scary but you're fine
no problem okay
some would say winning
winning for black yeah
so what are we up right now peace just a
piece
all you do you see my all of my threats
and then you just play the best moves
it's like just as easy yeah it's like
chess it's
easy as i said yeah so like somebody
who's on the line so i know that this is
easy you're fine tell me this like i
know i mean five is one thing and they
still play it how do you feel about that
f5 is
f5 is probably one of the most one of
the most typical defense attempts i
would say this is the way you would play
i mean yeah it's just i just know that
f5 is usually played against if you play
f5 i will play h5 yeah
and h6 and h6 and h6
and you're you're dead
okay it doesn't seem that dead but okay
i'm will i have even more prep i feel
free to put that on the board and let's
continue okay like it goes it is very
good for what
this is why i don't study openings i
just think
something random so that people can't
prepare so i play this and i know it's
losing is that a good strategy if it
keeps working
there's white you're playing this is
white i do this and you just you win so
fast because nobody can defend this
what's the defense e5 or something so my
threat is h5 h6
but i can't play rook h8 because then h5
and queen f3 so i can't do that
so you have to play king to f6 and run
away uh-huh okay that doesn't look very
difficult okay play king f6 but then but
then but the difficult part is that is
that c5 is here right that is not a
problem you can just shoot yeah just
trade everything okay so h6 though yep
and this is the last challenge it gets
it gets comple it stays complicated
forever
okay i mean okay play the best move i i
mean i can't this so here
this has to be a classical game but i
know i have to like an hour you have to
think about this
is this actually what happened like you
were just innocently streaming and a
dude storms and it's like oh yeah what
do you think about it
yeah
during spring classic against ray robson
because he played some play the craziest
one possible and then he played some
some
sideline and yeah and i had to spend 50
minutes just to calculate everything to
make sure they're not losing
mm-hmm
so knight e4 bishop g5 is coming at h7
so hold back i guess rocket [ __ ] i guess
just keep trying to train on rocket hit
queen
s3 um
maybe like king ed there should be seven
looks also do you see whites we have a
threat
no like it's the last century part like
if you play seven or anything yeah
yeah so i guess they don't see it though
like you know on they don't see night of
seven
it's really like if white ever gets to
play this is probably over so we have to
just move the knight away anywhere
literally anywhere i would say would
work yeah
but i think this move is probably
probably one of the better defenses and
then i can if i ever have and then i
think it's st the engine is always like
minus one or whatever but if you play
really really really long lines you it's
like that's like a little bit better and
usually i think one of the ideas for
white is to put as many things on f6 as
possible yeah but that's fine the knight
will go today
i'm not telling you i'm telling them
you played knight to d2 to e4 the other
knight goes to h7 queen goes on f3
yeah you eventually castle queenside you
now that i know that this is fine for
black and this is actually better for
black i would just instantly play it
with what would you recommend that they
they play this ever i mean
they see the only thing that i need is
because i just have such a immense sheer
amount of pure confidence in my in my
own strengths yeah and the only thing i
really need to know is that this this
thing that i'm playing is fine
so and then and then i just play it and
it works that is interesting and yeah i
don't really need any any specific
confirmation like
any special lines i'll figure it out i
know i know my position is better so so
i'm strong enough to figure stuff out in
a better position if if i knew my
position was worse it would be different
thing but my positions are always worse
but i know them but you know them
okay like sorry
actually
yeah i mean so that's literally what i
do and i feel like that works the best
for me i don't know anything but i know
but i just what's enough for me to know
is interesting yeah certain position is
fine that's how i mean you're probably
in the majority i'm the crazy one i
expect no i think no i think you're in
the maturity and i'm the crazy one okay
i'm looking at my level
i think in my level it's probably it's
it's unacceptable to do what i do
but yeah i do it anyway because it's
been working
one day one day somebody's going to shut
me down like for good
with this mentality and then i might
reconsider but you know and just like in
most things with life in life
uh really
a really strong negative event needs to
happen to to make you to force you to
make different changes in your lifestyle
you know that's probably one of those
cases with me where i have adopted this
this flawed mentality chess mentality
and then somebody really strong has to
come out and say no yeah
you need to go here
sit down study and and and yeah and
become yeah become a real chess player
and not just place a bunch of nonsense
in the opening all right i'm gonna let
you go though i gotta get back to things
thank you for your beaver battle thanks
for joining jonathan thank you thank you
thank you
uh should i make any more beaver content
or should i just as this is
looking like the last beaver gambit it's
looking exciting i mean i like the
definitely the the variation looks
commendable it looks it looks strong
commandable commendable write it down
computer gamut is commendable yeah
because once again it's really amazing
one of the least worst gambits out there
are you a believer in the beaver i of
course i am you heard it believer
commendable gambit thank you guys
all right have a good rest of stream
thank you thank you jonathan thanks for
joining all right